ما هي اهم الصعوبات التي تواجهكم في عملكم
نواجه الكثير من الصعوبات واولها ان حاجات
الناس الذين نهتم بهم تفوق طاقتنا
ومواردنا مثل ما شرحت ذلك ما عنيته بذلك
هو ان هناك الاف الاطفال فضفه الغربيه بل
العشرات الالاف بل ربما الملايين لهم
حاجات مختلفه في نفس الوقت يوجد في انحاء
اخرى من العالم ثروات كبيره وموارد عظيمه
ووفقا لخبرتنا فان الناس في هذه المنطقه
تحديدا يرغبون بالقيام بعمل الخير لذلك ما
نرغب به هو ربط الصله بين اصحاب الخير ومن
هم محتاجون له بنقل الموارد من هذه
المنطقه ومن امريكا الشماليه لاننا منظمه
امريكيه وترجمه ذلك ضمن مبادرات وبرامج
تنقذ حياه الاطفال
هناك عدد كبير من الاطفال الفلسطينيين كما
تعلم موجودين في الاردن في لبنان في سوريا
في العراق في مناطق مختلفه بسبب عمليه
التهجير هل هؤلاء يشبهلهم عمل منظمتكم
ايضا ولا تركزون فقط على الاطفال داخل
فلسطين
ديار ديار
انهم مسمورون ببرامجنا ففي منظمتنا
ومنظمات اخرى نحن لا نميز المشمولين
بنشاطنا وفقا للغه او العرق او الديني او
اللون او الجنسيه اي طفل يحتاج سواء كان
لبنانيا اردنيا فلسطينيا عراقيا سواء كان
شيعيا او سنيا مسيحيا او مسلما تساعده
منظمتنا وفقا لحاجته لهيته او جنسيته وقد
ساعدنا للكثيرين من الاطفال ليس فقط
الفلسطينيين بل من العراق وسوريا ولبنان
والاردن وحتى مصر ودول اخرى لا تشمل فقط
الاطفال الفلسطينيين اما انما الاطفال في
اي مكان اخر
يشمل الاطفال من كل الجنسيه والخلفيات
بالطبع لدينا موارد محدوده ونحن نرى الان
هذه الماساه في تركيا وسوريا ونامل لو كان
لدينا الموارد الكافيه مثل تلك التي تتوفر
الى الامم المتحده بما يسمح لنا
بالاستجابه والتحرك للمشاركه في اعمال
الاغاثه والانقاذ